hello deutsche welle hi everyone my name
is mike oh I and I come from war so this
is my father yawn we coming from Poland
to Berlin once again we are here quite
often and really enjoy Berlin we've been
here last time in July and it was really
really hot here now it's quite cold but
belly is so hot city and we would like
to take you for our journey to show you
our Berlin today
released as you rise
yeah so it's like quite impossible that
before 1989 all the place here was
basically empty and now you have also
these buildings like here that the
French ambassador is very very modern
building and here the academia kunst
this is Berlin you know this building
can always surprise you with something
crazy you know
okay so now we are going to the Ministry
of Finance which is the most important
ministry in Europe right now from the
biggest economy in Europe and this
building is very very interesting and
the history of this building and this is
the place that I would like to take you
right now
he's very complicated story about this
building because it was bull for Goering
and this was his headquarters after the
war in 1945 this basically came first
headquarters of the East German
Communist Party this is this is
something something amazing i think is
it was constructed you know after 1945
and this totally made with the bricks
and it shows like the new society of
east germany like working class of
germany and it was like a kind of i
think like a kind of tribute to them we
are on the Potsdamer Platz right now a
very special place for me in Berlin and
right now which is going up in this
building and we're going to see how old
earlene looks like from very high
it is unbelievable that when I was born
this place where we standing here was a
place where the East meet the west and
you just simply couldn't go through the
border you could be killed because when
you try to to pass the border guess you
later voiceover that was really really
good thank you very much Berlin we all
love Berlin and hope to see you again i
also invite you to Poland to war so and
my hometown Greer's no thank you dr.
Vella and see again bye